well a lot of people start celebrating
your independence day early on the 4th
of July in just a couple of hours a
Summerlin tradition is back this morning
Sherry swensk one of the MC's at this
year's Summerlin patriotic parade is
live this morning with a preview of the
big event Sherry good morning to you it
looks gorgeous out there
oh it's so nice John it is beautiful out
here we're right in the middle of the
street where the parade route will be
busy here within a couple of hours of
course everything is all set up the
flags uh this is we're right here at the
grandstand so man all the flags are
ready to go and oh it's going to be fun
we're going to be waving them now the
breezes aren't so rough yet but a little
bit later today it will be pretty Breezy
it's just gorgeous the sun is on its way
up this morning it is nice and dry the
stage is set for another fantastic
patriotic parade to celebrate the 4th of
July I've got Matt Walker with me here
from the Howard Hughes Corporation title
sponsor again this year good to see you
Matt happy fourth great to be here you
can feel the excitement building as
we're just a couple hours out and uh
we're really excited what's different
this year now the pandemic kind of set
things back a little bit for a year or
two we were virtual two years ago last
year not quite back a hundred percent
but what about this year bigger better
and more patriotic than ever we're
really excited and I think folks really
want that opportunity to come out and
rub Elvis with their friends and
neighbors and experience uh Independence
Day together we're expecting 50 000
people and uh 70 floats and so bigger
better than ever we're really excited to
have folks out not just from the
Summerlin area but from across the
valley yeah because it draws people from
everywhere and this is this parade
welcomes everybody in the community too
and that's what I love about it the
spirit the patriotism the salute to the
military and that's what gets me I can't
help it I tear up every parade when
we're in seeing because the military and
World War II veterans which aren't very
many left you know but just all branches
of the military and who's going to be
with us today and and why is that so
important to honor our military our
freedoms wouldn't be possible without
our heroes in uniform we're proud to
have folks here from Creech Nellis as
well as several veterans organizations
really is the centerpiece of the parade
while there's lots of fun things like
the Encanto float and some of our
professional sports teams it's really
important that our men and women in
uniform are are the key piece of the
Patriotic parade yeah we're going to
have a float for the Raiders the Vegas
golden knights the aviators everybody's
gonna be here that's right that's right
Logan Thompson and Zach White Cloud with
the gold Knights are going to be here
we're going to have several special
guests to accompany all the professional
sports teams floats and so it's a camp
Miss we're really excited wonderful in
addition to marching bands and the
performers it's just going to be so fun
and the big Inflatables they'll all be
here so we're looking forward to it we
hope you come down the pre parade kicks
off at 8 30 and the real parade at nine
o'clock the full parade so we'll see you
later this morning Brian Loftus myself
JC and Mercedes will all be here again
can't wait back to you John